hey what's going on is Bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday October 7th 2019 oh you know
you would think you would think 10
[ __ ] months in I wouldn't remember
what goddamn year it is but you know
this is a weird century you know as I
was growing up it was like it's the 70s
and then it became the 80s then it
became the 90s and in the 2000s and the
2000 the aughts is that what you called
them I know I've made this point before
but this is the last year of a decade
and nobody is saying [ __ ] that used to
always be a big deal politicians would
always be and as we head into the 80s I
envision a new America where people who
do the work actually get the body yeah
you know the 10 years later and as we
move on into an uncertain future as the
90s are upon us I think it's time for
people with vaginas to finally be heard
right and then as we got to the 2000s it
was just like it is a person who was
this person and that wants to be that
person and it's the odometer flips it's
you adieu Belletti all right
and I want to wait from 2009 to 2010 it
was just a happy new year I know this is
what I'm saying it's gonna pick up again
in 2029 and as we enter the 23rd age I
envision a future where robots to help
humans want to do and not the other way
around clap clap clap clap sorry you
know when you stay in a [ __ ] nice
hotel
and their hope deal is this place is
nice so it's going to be nice and
expensive and then you go to the [ __ ]
room and they have one-ply toilet paper
in the bathroom you know one ply toilet
paper it should be illegal it's like
what you see I don't even know what like
when you first start carving a baseball
bat and it's still kind of square put it
on a lathe and just imagine if you
stopped and just said okay that's a
[ __ ] bat that's what one flight oil I
don't know why because it's playoff
season playoff in baseball that's what I
don't know I'm trying to think of a
[ __ ] example it's like toilet paper
that isn't done yet it's like a
punishment you know and you really start
to understand the brilliance of people
in France with the bidet now I don't
want to get crass here but I gotta be
honest hosing off your staff fish is way
better than taking [ __ ] notebook
paper and trying to get the job done I
mean why don't you just leave the
[ __ ] three-ring binder spiral in
there while you're at it you [ __ ] and
if elected I will keep the robots at bay
and make sure people of all walks of
life all colors have access to three ply
toilet paper anyway
I was down at the MGM the second time I
played it back-to-back years two years
in a row right there right outside of
Washington DC had a great time thank you
so much to everybody who showed up Oh
Billy freckles well [ __ ] [ __ ]
polka dot shoulders over here I tried
out my new word it went great
okay now all I have to do is continue
doing it
so I'm in New York City I don't know if
I'm gonna be able to get out tonight um
press boy for the next three days
promoting my special and you're probably
thinking well Jesus Christ bill it came
out [ __ ] a month ago well that's the
way it's done now
you start promoting after it's out I
promote it on the west coast I mean
who's kidding who once you do once you
do Joe Rogan's podcast I mean you kind
of get the word out so but I'm trying to
do some different shows this time
through rather than the same old same
old that I've been doing I'm gonna try
to get in front of some different
peoples so I'll let you know I'll be
texting tweeting or whatever about the
different shows that I'm going to be
doing so but not all different not all
different like what are you doing today
bill today I'm doing barstool sports
some of my favorite people on the planet
and did you see that one would [ __ ]
Portnoy in mr. cats they were [ __ ]
talking about gambling it's like if
there's if there's three football games
on in one day
you you have to have money on all three
of them it was the most Pro gambling
thing I've ever my whole life even
though they knew everybody gambled they
tried to pay you know they always tried
to be lame ones like Jimmy the Greek
they try to like act like you were just
doing it for fun you know that it was
this thing to stay away from and blah
blah blah blah blah and I'm loving this
new world where people just [ __ ]
don't act like that you know because
everybody's gambling okay we already
tried to [ __ ] hold people's hands and
say don't do with this there's just
certain people like the game isn't
enough they need more action I was never
a good gambler I couldn't [ __ ] I
couldn't take it and then I'm already
paranoid and I'm already into conspiracy
theory I don't need to start putting
money on [ __ ] games and start
connecting the dots like Mel Gibson when
he was driving a cab in that movie right
so I kind of stay away from it but I
always I don't know I do enjoy the
sports book I'll actually gambled
yesterday I lost money I took the
[ __ ] Redskins and the points against
my Patriots and I went to the game I
mean I knew the Patriots were gonna win
but I was just like this is everyone
[ __ ] games would kick the [ __ ] out of
him in the first half and then there's
gonna be no more points scored for the
rest of the game which seems to happen a
lot in football games whatever reason
it's like Jesus Christ they keep this
job there's a point and then nothing
happens in the second half maybe a field
goal I just had that vibe plus everybody
I knew was like dude you gotta bury the
pad see they're totally gonna cover and
whenever that [ __ ] happens that's my
gambling theory it literally has nothing
to do with the game it's just too many
[ __ ] people who look like they're as
dumb as me are saying it's a lock so I
always like I'll throw [ __ ] I'll
throw a little cash on the other side
just for the [ __ ] of it just to see if
my Theory's right and I ended up being
wrong but watching the game I can be
honest I have no idea how good or bad
the Patriots are right now is everybody
they have five an hour just gotta is
just a year they go undefeated defeated
defeated I know we have a lot of guys
out yesterday but I don't know if you're
really honest about the Patriots we had
the same September schedule as a top
ranked college football team like
Alabama they'll just play three
shit-bomb teams and maybe somebody kind
of ranked like you got to understand the
Patriots played okay what do we got we
got we played three well I guess the
first week they're not okay the combined
record of the people that we played last
I checked we played three oh and three
teams a three no team in an Owen four
team so we've only played one [ __ ]
team that's actually one but that team
was undefeated and when we played him
that that was not like an easy victory
so it's kind of hard to gauge where
they're at this is my theory I think the
Patriots are where they're at every year
this time of year where Pats fans would
be nervous going like what's going on
with our offensive line can't protect
Brady what's going on with our
defensive secondary seems like if a
running back gets into the into the the
secondary there's a little lazy
technique there with the tackling
sometimes running backs are getting big
[ __ ] gains and then every year in
November Belichick tights it tightens it
down all the screws down everything gets
in line and then we go on a great run
here I think that that's actually where
we're at you just can't see it because
we've been playing such shitty [ __ ]
teams the Patriots already in Week five
are the last undefeated team out there
and that's why I think that that [ __ ]
72 dolphins thing I don't think it's
ever going to be broken because the 72
dolphins had to win two less games there
wasn't the 24-hour [ __ ] media circus
that the 1580s PN channels and all Fox
Sports and podcasting and all this [ __ ]
is and lastly but not leastly there was
no parity in the NFL when the 72
dolphins want you know they just wasn't
there was just like there was like three
big teams and they beat the [ __ ] out of
everybody unless they played each other
and if you look at the you know the 70s
right through the 80s it was just all
about dynasties you know the Cowboys had
their run the Steelers won for dolphins
one two the Raiders won 3 then the
Redskins they won 3 I guess into the 90s
we count that one all right the 49ers
won four that's kind of the way it was
as opposed to now where it's weird cuz
the Patriots are a dynasty but like I'm
just saying as far as like I don't know
we win a lot of close games it just you
know
well the Steelers came to Talent
seventies they just beat the [ __ ] out of
you and it was over the Cowboys came
they beat the [ __ ] out of you 49ers came
it's like it was like [ __ ] 28
before you before you know even got to
the half it seemed and then everybody
know if your team sucked you just
[ __ ] sucked you weren't like in it at
the end of the game you know if you were
down by seven and you sucked your team
went out there and it was three and out
and it was [ __ ] over but now you're
down by seven with two or three minutes
left and every every team's every
[ __ ] team drives right down the field
I don't you know I don't know I really
kind of realized how [ __ ] old I am
yesterday when I went to that Washington
Redskins stadium which I actually really
like it's weird it's like only 22 years
old but it seems a lot older and you
know they're the only NFL team that
still has like a band which is a nod to
how long they've been in the NFL
obviously including their logo the fact
that they would [ __ ] come out and be
called the Redskins really amazes me
that there was never a team called the
slaves we were gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] out
that part of our history why we didn't
continue on that route is actually like
maybe commendable or surprising I don't
know which way to go with that but
anyways I was there and I got to be the
[ __ ] sound system and that thing was
so goddamn loud I was actually hanging
with this Redskins fan where I was
sitting and he really knew the game and
he was fun to talk to but he was
shouting over the [ __ ] loudspeaker
right into my you know it like when you
were in a bar in some meat market and
you're trying to hit on some chicken you
just screaming in her [ __ ] ear and
then she yells back at you and two got
the high-pitched thing and it's like you
feel it in your teeth that's what it was
little he had to move down but it was
just they were playing like Twisted
Sister and all this metal from like my
for whatever reason my age group along
with like
I guess he did all three they had the
[ __ ] Little John yeah [ __ ] going on
and then they had a lot of this weird
[ __ ] that I don't even understand you
know that [ __ ] albums that get
produced in somebody's apartment type
music they had that all going on
underneath they would be playing Twisted
Sister you know I wanna rock they be
playing that was some guy over the top
yelled over the music and a be like
that's our ask a third and it was like
my ears are so [ __ ] shot from loud
music and playing drums and stuff that I
I was joking with my buddy that I was
ready to give up whatever information
the Redskins wanted from me by the
second quarter so I I hate missing any
part of the game when I'm in at a game
and finally I just had to walk away from
this guy's yelling in my ear and I just
went out and I got a couple of napkins
tore off a few pieces and shoved them in
my [ __ ] ear so I could go back in and
then after that I really enjoyed the
game but I I had to get kind of a sad
moment my life I had to admit that a
football game is too loud for me I I
gotta remember to bring my earplugs that
happened to me when I went to the
Brooklyn Nets game the thing about it is
two is the worst of franchises record is
the louder it's going to be as far as
fake noise pumped into a stadium and
it's kind of weird like all these all
these franchises that I've gotten busted
for pumping fake crowd noise you know
into their arenas or their stadiums or
whatever and so I think the loophole is
anytime there's a stop at your play
there's not going to be one second there
was a few times where the guy didn't hit
play and it was so nice like your sense
of smell came back he could smell the
grass on the field before they just
crank the music again and your teeth
started [ __ ] chattering it was like
obnoxious but having said that it's a
[ __ ] great Stadium it's
great franchise and it has a really
great fan base and overall just a really
positive [ __ ] experience so if you're
older like me if you went to saw too
many [ __ ] bands when you were a kid
and played drums in that type of [ __ ] I
definitely suggest bringing the [ __ ]
earplugs because they got the sound
system [ __ ] cranked up past I think
when you get the odometer it gets on the
other side of 50 just you should always
have earplugs with you it was
embarrassing man I tried to tough it out
through the first half going I can't be
this old it can't be to a football game
can't be too loud come on man it just
you know it just was playing hot for
teacher and music from my [ __ ]
generation that was now too loud for me
so there you go there's a new this is
what this podcast is coming I think I've
begun the dying process
so anyways Patriots came out you know we
led we let up a horrific run or an
incredible run if you're a Redskins fan
for a touchdown where it was just like
it almost looked like you know when one
of those make-a-wish kids runs for a
[ __ ] touchdown you know and no one's
really gonna try you gotta let the kid
you got to let the kid win it's his
[ __ ] fantasy they kinda I feel like
there was make-a-wish level tackling on
that run that that [ __ ] guy did it was
like literally two defensive backs were
on him like had their arms around him
and just sort of slid down like it was a
greased pole that's the second time
that's happened I think was in the
Buffalo game where this running back got
into our secondary and then like one of
our defensive backs you know like when
somebody scores a touchdown they jump up
there and they bumped shoulders that's
basically what he did to him like he was
anticipating the touchdown this guy was
gonna score 80 yards later so in the
words of Peyton Manning I think we had
protection issues and other than that
you know I don't know I don't know how
to gauge the Patriots beating at Owen 14
and three oh and three teams and then
having a tough game against the three
and OH team so I would say we're
pretty much middle of the road here in
this weird world where the [ __ ]
Baltimore Colts and their franchise
quarterback like two seconds before the
season starts says yeah I'm not playing
anymore they somehow beat the Kansas
City Chiefs in an away game
I got no idea but all I know is somehow
we have home-field throughout the
playoffs
we have home-field so I don't know who
we have [ __ ] next week I think we
play the Dolphins again I mean it's
[ __ ] it's ridiculous and this is
what's so [ __ ] funny about virzi
telling me that it's over
totally Paul virzi has seen enough
Thanks calling it early people Patriots
schedule let's see what we got there's
got to be some tough games coming up all
right Thursday we got the Giants now who
would the Giants who knows they got a
new [ __ ] quarterback we play this
Thursday actually we got the Giants then
we got the Jets maybe their quarterbacks
doesn't have mono anymore if he stops
taking chicks to the prom maybe he can
get over that then we got the Browns
Browns of sort of middle of the road
then we got the Ravens they always got a
great defense they always play tough
Eagles are a good team I think Cowboys
who knows who the [ __ ] they are
are they good are they Baloo I don't
know Texans Chiefs say you go that'll be
a tough game Bengals stink we play the
bills they're a good team and then we
play the [ __ ] dollar guy I think we
have like four tough games this year I
don't know who the [ __ ] knows but uh we
shall see but I know I do take a lot of
confidence in the fact that Paul bernzy
told me it was over
speaking of Paul virzi your New York
Yankees - and OH - and oh just [ __ ]
mowing down the pitching of your
Minnesota Twins
scouring all kinds of [ __ ] runs I've
been you know working and everything so
I've just been kind of glancing at the
TV and this is this is the the sports
that this that basically this series
that I've been waiting for because I
love October baseball even though I've
been too busy to watch a lot of it is
the Yankees versus the Astros that is
the world series to me and I think
that's going to be some incredible
incredible baseball you got the Yankees
who are firing on all cylinders and then
how weird is that to say in a Boston
accent and then you got [ __ ] the
Astros who I think a [ __ ] pissed off
because even though they won one two
years ago I don't feel like they feel
like they're respected you know and
they're not they're from Houston nobody
gives a [ __ ] people do not give a [ __ ]
you know we were talking about that
quarterback there that the Seahawks have
the Fluxus named Riley O'Hara how come I
can't remember anybody's [ __ ] names
anymore once you get if you get past a
certain it's over it's over it's the
football games are too loud you can't
remember players names Seattle Seahawks
QB his name is Russell Wilson of course
Jesus Christ that [ __ ] guy if that
guy played in [ __ ] New York City or
Los Angeles you'd never hear the end of
them you know and they asked row same
[ __ ] thing I've always you know I've
been saying this for a while if the
[ __ ] San Antonio Spurs won five
[ __ ] titles in a media town it did
it's weird
so I think the Astros feel disrespected
you know they're like a bag of Hornets
right now that got shook up and they're
about ready to let him out so I I think
that those guys are like you know [ __ ]
the Red Sox they think they pissed that
they got beaten biased last year and and
everybody you know you just if the
Yankees are playing well the whole media
world just looks to that a Mickey Mantle
they just start [ __ ] showing those
black and white films I'm from back in
the day right then it goes into Reggie
hitting his three home runs and then
Derek Jeter's run and
the Astros are over there like I think
we want some games this year too you
know we got some barbecue down here why
don't you show black-and-white footage
of people with the smoke
I think Babe Ruth got so [ __ ] fast so
I think that they feel disrespected and
it's just gonna be a an amazing amazing
series that's what I am I am hoping for
and and I think the winner of that
series is gonna win the whole [ __ ]
thing that's not really taking a big
risk but uh that's the series that I
want to watch and I'm on the road here
for the next [ __ ] week and I feel
like maybe next weekend the series will
start so I'll get to what and I'll be
back in LA I'll get to watch the whole
thing I think it's gonna be incredible
and as I've mentioned before Casey I
know people dip in and out of the
podcast the New York Yankees are such a
successful franchise that if they don't
go to the World Series this year this is
the first time since the nineteen teens
you know a hundred years ago in a
hundred years that they there was a
decade went by that they didn't at least
make it to the World Series and only one
decade the 80s was the only one that
they didn't they made it to the series
in 81 but that was the only decade they
didn't win a World Series that's one of
the most the sickest [ __ ] stats in
sports for some reason that isn't
brought up I think people will bring up
you know name one of the most impressive
stats of the [ __ ] have broken or
whatever you know for a while was that
guy who did the long jump and [ __ ]
Mexico City and people were bitching
about the altitude and then somebody
came along you know with the new robot
legs and [ __ ] you know vitamins that
these guys take and they ended up
breaking that they'll talk about
DiMaggio's [ __ ] 56-game hitting
streak they'll talk about the 72
dolphins and blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah all that [ __ ] [ __ ] but I
got to be honest with you this is one
that never gets brought up I think it's
amazing when you think about ownership
and how free agency and all how many
people come and go and all of that to
consistently
you know just be there as much as I hate
it I hate I gotta be honest with you I
don't [ __ ] hate it anymore you know I
saw somebody [ __ ] put out a content
of Red Sox fan put out a kunti tweet
about the Yankees it actually
disappointed me I was like come on man
you're better than that
all right it's fight it's it really is
over they might think that the waste of
energy rooting against another team
success when your team isn't even in the
[ __ ] playoffs just the [ __ ] pure
waste of [ __ ] energy that that is
[Music]
like I remember this a few years ago
when the Red Sox were had a big league
and then choked it away in the in
September and this Yankee fan I heard
and heard from in 10 years called me up
you footballs did it was [ __ ] it was
pathetic
it's like I cuz he let me into his world
it's like oh my god your team isn't in
it and you're actually sitting there
like your fandom now you've been reduced
to just rooting against my team's
success I just saw it I saw his sad life
I saw the weight he was putting on and
you standing up that dumb [ __ ] you do
walking around your apartment like like
I gotta be honest is a huge sports fan I
can't tell you how liberating it is to
let go of hating your [ __ ] rival that
I I just I don't I don't want to do it
anymore
I just don't god bless them if they do
it it's an amazing sports feat to watch
I'm still always gonna root for the Red
Sox but what my team isn't in it I'm not
gonna [ __ ] sit here and root against
other [ __ ] teams I don't give a [ __ ]
rooting for the [ __ ] Dodgers to
finally push through as much as I'm not
a fan of LA sports fans and how people
you know just I don't know that's that
whole [ __ ] I'm gonna stab you after
the game vibe out there with the
combination of not being able to
intelligently talk about the game I'm
still rooting for them who else who else
is in it I like
the Astros I'd like everybody I like the
twins it's a great [ __ ] baseball sand
I don't give a [ __ ] god bless everybody
it's liberating it's liberating and I
was thinking that like how the [ __ ] did
I get so wound up in all of this sports
[ __ ] and it just finally dawned on me
while growing up outside of Boston such
an unbelievable like sports intensive
experience aside from the fact that we
used to lose all the time other than the
Celtics I just realized that the number
one baseball rivalry is the Boston Red
Sox versus the [ __ ] New York Yankees
the number one hockey rivalry is the
Boston Bruins first the Canadiens the
number one [ __ ] I mean historically
speaking there's been errors you know
I'm not trying to disrespect the great
you know Red Wings Avalanche rivalry but
as far as the overall arc of the history
of the game it's been the Boston Bruins
Montreal Canadiens basketballs been the
Boston Celtics first the Lakers so three
out of four we are involved in the
biggest [ __ ] rival rivalry out there
so the hatred is like through the roof
so we have like Michigan Ohio State
times three and there really is no
let-up I guess when you get to football
and and I'd say the Patriots sense like
you know the Spygate thing it's just
been kind of like since then it's just
yeah I don't there's not but I guess we
had the thing with the Colts for a while
never got the thing with the Chiefs we
had a thing with the Jets for a while
but there was no like clear-cut like I
asked Keith Robinson the other day
hilarious he thought we were trying to
figure out what's what do you think the
biggest [ __ ] didn't what's the Lakers
Celtics of football and I don't mean
like right now I just mean throughout
history what's the biggest one I
actually I was thinking is a cowboy
Steelers it was that when I was growing
up then it was sort of Cowboys 14 I had
49ers for a little bit I kind of think
it's Cowboys somebody but the Cowboys
has just not been good enough for so
[ __ ] long
kind of died down like people used to
[ __ ] hate the Cowboys their whole
clean-cut image is half that players
were getting busted for hookers and
cocaine on the side very notre dame
esque you know holier-than-thou
clean-cut hottest [ __ ] cheerleaders
greatest [ __ ] you know cheerleader
outfits ever no one's ever going to come
up with better [ __ ] outfits than them
you know it's hilarious you know the
Redskins probably tried but they were
sort of saddled by their their their
name you know what I mean I think you
can hear the Cowboys you can [ __ ] that
up right
you can't [ __ ] up Native Americans
we've gone far enough
we can't [ __ ] do this anyways I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
here so I watched a ton of sports I had
a bunch of my buddies from high school
came down and hung out and we all went
to the Patriots Redskins game we had
such a [ __ ] great time and I don't
know that's it that's a good one if you
want to go see your team on the road
that just check out that [ __ ] stadium
it's weird man it's like a new old
stadium and when the band comes out and
starts playing hail to the Redskins they
have literally have a [ __ ] band I
wish more the old-school NFL teams did
that it gave you more of a sense of
history because NFL is weird with their
history where it's just like yeah a
bunch of people played and did some
great things but [ __ ] them nothing
counts until Superbowl one [ __ ] our
first 30 years see you later everybody
Sammy Baugh great job Jim Brown great
job [ __ ] all your records [ __ ] all your
championships we're not even going to
address them we'll mention them as an
aside and then they won the NFL title
but the first Super Bowl Joe Namath gets
more [ __ ] love than [ __ ] Jim Brown
it's unbelievable no disrespect to
[ __ ] Broadway Joe
because they were all about the money
because when he [ __ ] won the greatest
thing that ever happened the NFL was him
beating the [ __ ] Colts and then they
married those two leaks and then they
went from being millionaires into
billionaires and that's what they give a
[ __ ] about right now Jesus Christ by the
way how about [ __ ] Mason Rudolph
getting knocked out they bring the
goddamn gurney out there and the [ __ ]
thing breaks like it's the XFL of the
USFL the world football league was like
it's you know and then he's got to stand
up this poor bastard and walk off the
field wearing a helmet without a face
mask which by the way I think they just
solved the helmet-to-helmet hit if they
would just get rid of the face mask
you know actually they should just go
back to leather helmets you know you
don't see a lot of helmet Dan you know
there's no helmet to helmet hitting in
rugby I mean obviously the loophole
there's they're not wearing helmets but
generally speaking yeah they lead with
their shoulders if you have a helmet on
all of a sudden you [ __ ] gonna use
your head as a goddamn weapon there all
right does that make any sense have I
bored you to tears with this forget I'm
getting bored with it did I just talk I
just talked for a [ __ ] half-hour
about nothing Sports Jesus Christ let's
get to the [ __ ] advertising here more
nothing hail to the I mean let's see
what the [ __ ] the lyrics are to that
hail to the king the chief the Redskins
there we go
one of the odds is gonna be some
questionable lyrics it's usually comes
during the second verse all right here
we go way the hell is in history nobody
cares lyrics hail to the Redskins hail
victory Braves on the warpath okay it's
a little weird their fight for oldc
runner passing score we want a lot more
typical Washington DC yeah a lot more
for yourselves you're not gonna spread
it to Joe Sixpack are you
them swamp them look in the old 23
skidoo touchdown let's the points or
fight on Fight on till you have one sons
of Washington rah rah rah wow this is
really old sons up Washington rah rah
rah rah
I don't know the melody goes here hail
to the rescue victim
Braves on the warpath there you go
the song's original first stanza is
often mistakenly thought to have ended
with fight for Old Dixie but in fact
this line was only used between 59 and
61 whoops as a glance at contemporary
game okay yeah there's always there's
always that [ __ ] line make it great
again all right let's get let's get to
the advertising here
what the [ __ ] am i what the hell is my
[ __ ] oh there it is Gmail Gmail okay
where are we here in inbox
I couldn't copy and paste it this week
everybody all right oh look who's here
old zip crudo hail to zip recruiter
makes hiring easy
somebody just walked up and quit he'll
have a replacement in five minutes
hiring can be slow process cafe Altera's
see oh oh whatever happened to CEOs
chief operating officer Dylan are you
guys trying to [ __ ] me up here miski
wits
Miska wits Dylan Miska wits now there's
a name that doesn't make any sense
Dylan Miska which I don't think anybody
named Dylan ever had the last name it's
go it's a name over the last name it's
go it's never had the first name Dylan
needed to have
Patrick Schwartz trying to combine
nationalities here
Wolfgang o'houlihan alright needed to
hire a director of coffee for his
organic coffee company but he was having
trouble finding qualified applicants so
he switched to old zip zip recruit it
doesn't depend on candidates finding you
it finds them for you you know it's like
comedians who didn't choose comedy
comedy chose them so one of my favorite
[ __ ] douche chill things to ever read
a comedian say I don't feel like I chose
comedy as much as comedy chose me it's
technology identifies people with the
right experience and invites them to
apply to your job I don't know Kevin
Hart so you get Pat well you know what
if Oh [ __ ] dr. Phil you zip he could
get to know Dylan posted his job on zip
recruiter and said he was impressed by
how quickly he had great candidates
apply I like how this is Dylan what's
his name Miska wits I like how he T
didn't quite give it up to him
I used it recruiter I use it recruiter
and I was impressed by how quickly you
know everybody's got a parent like that
right doesn't quite give it up and you
spend your whole life chasing that
carrot come on give me some of bro he
also used it recruiter candidate ratings
feature to filter his applicants and
found it very satisfying
I'm kidding Keenan said so you could
focus on the most relevant once you
imagine if you went on a first date with
a woman she's like did you have fun and
be like you know I was very impressed
with you should be very impressed with
what am i a vegetable chopper whenever
he call those [ __ ] things that's how
Dylan found his new director of coffee
in just a few days
to be honest it really seems like zipper
crews did a hell of a job for Dylan
Miska what's here and he really didn't
give it up with the I was very impressed
how about a moment of silence for the
new director of coffee he's gonna work
for this unimpressed son-of-a-bitch here
which results like that it's no wonder
four out of five employees who post on
zip recruiter get a quality job
candidate within the first few days CTA
and tagline must read I read everything
including your instructions CY zip
recruiter is affected for businesses of
all sizes try zip recruiter for free at
our website website zip recruit comm / /
that's it prakruti comm / / spell it out
z IP r e crui ter dot-com / / all right
policy genius have you seen policy oh my
god it is [ __ ] genius it is so
brilliant policy genius halloween is on
the way everybody which means it's time
to break out the rubber spiders fake
cobwebs and jack-o'-lanterns unless
you're a real creep maybe it's time to
clean up your house policy genius is the
easy way to shop for life insurance
online in minutes you can compare quotes
are they comparing Halloween to actually
dying I love this copy you can compare
quotes from top insurers to find your
best price once you apply the policy
genius like The Ohio State the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and red tape and policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they can also help you find the right
home insurance auto insurance and
disability insurance this October
take the scariness out of buying life
insurance with policy genius there's
nothing scarier than dying and leaving
your family destitute get your life
insurance alright get over your own
[ __ ] mortality and get it done then
once you have life insurance you can go
out and get that pizza with the cheese
in the crust and have a great time go to
Paul
see genius comm get quotes and apply in
minutes you can do the whole thing on
your phone right now
policy genius the easy way to compare
and buy life insurance all right and
lastly but not leastly stamps.com the
holidays are coming up quickly get
started with stamps.com today so that
you're ready for holiday for the holiday
rush stamps.com brings all the services
of the post office right to you to my
computer I can buy and print US postage
for any letter any package right from my
home office all right it could be your
home office - this copies written a
little bit weird where I use the word my
you can do it at yours alright I want to
give you guys the feeling that you can
make this happen I know when you guys
listen to me read out loud you know a
lot of things that I talk about
immediately become unattainable right I
know that I have a devastatingly
powerful voice and the way that I just
make the words mine I can even schedule
pickup with the mail carrier avoiding
that LA traffic I why is this did a
[ __ ] NFL wide receiver write this
[ __ ] copy I haven't gotten to the
best part yet but stamps.com
oh you get five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 40% off
Priority Mail why would anyone pay full
price when they don't have to stamps
calm is a no-brainer saving you time and
money it's no wonder 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm right
now my listeners get a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale without
any long-term commitment just go to
stamp com click on click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Burpee you are our that
stamps commenter burrow
stamps.com go to the post office again
alright and with that let's read some of
the
the questions here for the week wait a
minute
yeah we're good Leo we got it
all right I love the little production
value that I have by the way everybody
how about a shout out to the CIA men huh
how sloppier they get with their [ __ ]
work
I read the flu some drones that blow up
some blah blah blah blah blah Jesus can
you tighten up your game come on CIA it
used to be better at it than that
all right fat people in Houston
documentary oh Jesus Christ I would love
to watch this hey old Beantown Billy I
stumbled across this video about a
documentary on obesity in Houston and
reminded me of you ranting about fat
people at airports just wanted to hear
your opinions on this documentary thanks
and keep up the great work I got to see
this thing I'll give you the name of it
here well that's 51 America's fattest
city obesity full real documentary so
just how have these larger-than-life
Texans ended up so big and what is it
about Texas that produces the fattest
people in the fattest country in the
world you know I think that's a real
negative way of saying the greatest
company in the world you know I mean
come on every you know back in the day
if you were fat that meant you were rich
right America's fattest city meets some
meets some larger-than-life locals to
find out oh my god how do you not watch
every [ __ ] frame of this one all
right Oh
whoever's a sound engineer for this
documentary was should be fired the
background music is annoying you can't
even hear what said 600 pounds and
cannot walk is not okay poor woman is
deluded if she thinks she looks all
right fat kid he has a faster metabolism
so we can eat more without gaining
weight like I do skinny kid he eats all
the food plus half of mine okay I'm in I
don't give a [ __ ] how bad
the music is you guys want here so few
more the reviews all right here okay
here's a solution here this must be a
doctor weighing in or just some typical
douche on YouTube the solution for
weight loss is not doing a temporary
diet it's about changing your eating
habits permanently exclamation point
well there's the Oprah Winfrey talk show
[ __ ] applause break right there the
strangest thing in this whole
documentary is driving your kid 50 feet
to the bus stop oh my god do they put
them in the back of the [ __ ] tractor
or some [ __ ] like they do when they
bring the pigs to slaughter I love how
they were all delusional there's
somebody not carrying the people of fat
I like that one
the music is draining out the narration
again background music is far too loud
and distracting that's weird that they
didn't mix it correctly maybe it was
mixed correctly and then got compressed
a pill stop talking shop alright you're
right I apologize well I'm definitely
gonna check that out fat people in
Houston any our fault [ __ ] foods that
goddamn good they got Texas toast
we got Houston pancakes
we slather the [ __ ] barbecue sauce
alright your back and shoulder dear
Billy Brokeback Mountain I can only
imagine listen to you talking about your
shoulder and back ailments for so long
before I have to help I was reluctant at
first to offer solution not advice I
like this person talking [ __ ] here
because it involves big words and things
in the gym you'll find queer meaning
weird or odd you need to use that big
stupid foam roller lying around the gym
and roll out your piriformis that's the
muscle that's part of your pasty
freckled ass I do use that it tends to
get tight and pull your tailbone down to
the side your shoulder is [ __ ] up from
your chest and
Latta misis big word scary having knots
and adhesions basically both muscles are
pulling your shoulder from its socket
you can search on how to do those on
YouTube just like everything else I hope
this helps feel better you freckled [ __ ]
yeah I kind of learned that over the
last few years when I had a sciatic
nerve it was just basically from doing
the road for 20 years sitting on planes
and then getting in a car and driving
for hours and not stretching and and not
not having a masseuse and then also in
the 80s you know you did your back a
little bit but you miss back day you did
your legs but you miss leg day but you
never miss benching so you know and
[ __ ] curling and and triceps and all
that [ __ ] so basically the front part of
me got tighter than the back and it
wasn't balanced and it's the weirdest
[ __ ] thing cuz you don't have to be
this gigantic [ __ ] muscle-bound
person which obviously I'm not I don't
know if you guys have ever noticed I do
blend into a crowd
except for my Maisie day head floating
down the [ __ ] Street but other than
that it you don't have to be overly
muscular to [ __ ] up your shoulders doing
[ __ ] like that you just have to not be
balanced so I learned that the hard way
but I appreciate that sir I do have a
foam roller I got those little [ __ ]
ball things that you know are different
sizes because actually I would say the
foam roller isn't is helpful is one of
those little hard balls because then you
can kind of like this is great put some
hard balls on your ass everybody you can
control like the pressure and you can
also roll it out and though the foam
roller what you have to watch out is on
your side whatever at the top of your
femur is right there don't roll over
that because that'll get you'll [ __ ]
that thing up you got to make sure you
go around that but then I'm sure they
explained all that but I really
appreciate what you don't so you're
actually trying to improve my quality of
life people like let's take time is
there anything more important than your
health when it comes to your mood the
you cheat people around you all right
climate change either isn't real or
doesn't matter all right I like this
person this person's going hard hey
Billy balderdash
I didn't know how willing you are to I
don't know how willing you are to change
your opinion on global warming dude I
hope you're right but I thought it would
be fun for you to get a different look
on the subject all right exactly
[ __ ] what scientists are saying I'm
gonna listen to a podcast listener who's
not even smart enough to not listen to
this podcast all right so as the title
suggests I think that manmade climate
change isn't real and if it is it
doesn't matter okay you've made some big
statements there sir so far this is all
reading like dialogue that a
stenographer picked up at a bar about
three drinks in first let's get into why
it doesn't matter basically if climate
change is truly man-made there's no
reason to worry about it because there's
nothing at all we can do about it the
reason for this starts with China and
how we can model world carbon output
based on their development you mean the
environmental disaster that is China
they have way too many [ __ ] people
you know I felt bad for the people
living over there the way they have to
live unless it's all propaganda seems to
me they're [ __ ] air is filthy over
there because they got too many people
for decades because they were stuck in
pre and in a pre industrial revolution
era China was a carbon- country I don't
know what that means
over the decades as they began to
develop all because they didn't have
machines that they weren't really
producing a lot of pollution over the
decades as they began to develop they
started producing more and more
pollution as it stands right now China
spews out more carbon dioxide than the
US Wow European Union and Russia
combined here's a source alright by
itself that might be a problem we can
deal with however India
a country with just as many people is
just now beginning to industrialize the
asia-pacific region of the globe which
includes China and India now produces 50
percent of all global carbon emissions
and it will only continue to grow as
India develops like China did yeah
that's scary because I learned when I
travelled over there when I did
Singapore or Hong Kong in Mumbai India
there was more people in that
geographical circle within the circle of
that flight which is more like a
triangle whatever there was more people
living within that part of the world
than there was in the rest of the world
so if they all start living like fat
Americans yeah we're in trouble
this is because as each undeveloped
country begins to industrialize its
immediately starts using the cheapest
forms of energy producing the most
readily available to accommodate a
massive spike in energy needs weight
immediately starts using the cheapest
forms of energy production oh that are
most readily available to accommodate a
massive spike in energy needs which
means gas and coal so India with its
billions with its billion people will
start producing as much carbon as China
and Africa is quickly following behind
them yeah we're kind of [ __ ] I don't
understand why oil men won't just
convert to solar just convert your
business model
god forbid you don't [ __ ] make a
zillion dollars this month and then you
could own the Sun you have enough money
to produce legislation that you own all
solar power people would still be under
your thumb you'd still have all the
power and you know you just keep getting
more power throughout history except
you're we could continue living so I
don't understand why can't all companies
just oppress us with solar energy anyway
so unless we are willing to just nuke
their population and sterilize the
survivors there's no way to stop the
climate change process well I have to be
is over the top and his craze
is that is if what scientists are saying
is gonna happen then at some point that
won't be a crazy over-the-top joke or a
sci-fi thing that's gonna be like you
know at some point when people are just
getting down to being able to survive on
this [ __ ] planet what human life will
mean will be no more than when a fly
comes into your house and you just grab
a swatter and wha - however that leads
me to explain why I think manmade
climate change is a hoax when it comes
to climate change research the common
complaint that research that tries to
challenge consensus is that it's funded
by the oil company that begs the
question though who funds the climate
studies that support it if you take a
look at most climate research and note
who paid for the studies you begin to
notice a trend in the list of fine
answers and it just so happens to be our
old friends the international bankers if
you take a look at the World Bank page
regarding climate finance you'll notice
that the group that dedicated 30 billion
dollars in climate change climate
related activities in 2019 alone a
significant part of which is dedicated
to climate research this is just one
Banking Group of many doing the same
thing so why are the banks financing
people who claim that humans are
affecting the global climate wait why
are they financing people who clone okay
there are two main reasons Jesus Christ
I feel like I'm on [ __ ] 60 minutes
first is financial gain not only will
the bank's get trillions upon trillions
of dollars in financing the
infrastructure changes made in the name
of climate change but there is something
called emissions trading where
individual companies buy and sell what
are essentially stocks that are meant to
offset the amount of greenhouse gases
they produce I hate [ __ ] people that
worship money
they could be bought from the big banks
and sold on the market based on the
price
I I can't this is too [ __ ] depressing
it's too [ __ ] depressing you know
something I'll just read the rest and
I'm sure this interests you guys more
than the dumb [ __ ] that comes out of my
mouth considering I wasted 30 minutes
talking about
stadiums and [ __ ] fight songs of
sports teams these can be bought from
the big banks and sold on the market on
the price changes caused by changing
environmental regulations it's more
complicated than what can be said here
so you can read more here alright second
I guess I'll post these [ __ ] links I
never do though second is that they are
trying it's actually Wikipedia carbon
emissions trading Ziff you search that
second is that they are trying to shape
people's minds they want people to not
only accept lower living standards but
to want lower living standards they want
people eating bugs and dead bodies what
seriously there's dozens of articles
about this see this example dude I'm too
[ __ ] paranoid to read this edible
insects save planet global warming tasty
trend trendy tasty trendy I'm supposed
to read a [ __ ] article it says tasty
trendy that's about eating bugs here's
my question why won't they just [ __ ]
implement some laws to try to curb the
population growth and this is from the
New York Post scientists suggests eating
human flesh to fight climate change Wow
I mean this has to be like how far this
is how [ __ ] bad it's getting and they
want them to accept everyone this it
can't be [ __ ] I have to go now I have to
collect click on that one
scientists suggests eating human flesh
to fight climate change well I'll tell
you right now this brings us back to
Houston because if you want to eat
anybody you want those [ __ ]
marbled rib eyed people down there and
they don't exercise it'll be like eating
veal a Swedish scientists speaking at
Stockholm summit last week offered an
unusual possible tactic in combating
global climate change eating human flesh
oh my god is there [ __ ] video footage
of this speech Stockholm School of
Economics professor and researcher
Magnus solder lund they ago reportedly
said he believes eating human meat
derived from dead bodies might be able
to help save the human race if only a
world society were awakened to the idea
sorta --lens argument for human
cannibalism was front and center during
a panel talk called can you imagine
eating human flesh oh my god so they
have a triple-decker sandwich with like
doll arms coming out of it that's
[ __ ] hilarious
sorry limbs argument for the human
cannibalism was okay ba ba ba at the
gastro summit conservative taboos
against capitalism conservative taboos
against campbell who said can change
over time if people see people simply
tried eating human flesh some there they
going to start farming people some of
the talking points at the seminar i
remember vaguely reading animal
pharmacists the same thing when the
animals start eating us or rebel against
us some of the talking points at the
seminar included what the humans were
too selfish to live sustainably and if
cannibalism is the solution to the food
sustainability in the future when at
Lissa's this is the direction we're
headed in that this is somebody is
anticipating we're gonna run like all
the animals are gonna be dead who have
to eat each other when asked during an
interview after his talk if he
personally would try human flesh
soderlund said he was open to the idea i
feel somewhat hesitant but to not appear
overly conservative i've had to say I'd
be open to at least tasting it
so was Jeffrey
I'm a [ __ ] environmentalist because
he was helping the world population and
then also not eating animals I'm [ __ ]
beyond confused her he suggested more
plausible options such as eating pets
and insects before human meat becomes
the next cuisine trend however history
shows that there are potential health
risks to cannibalism
I tried in Papua New Guinea practice
eating the dead as an alternative to
allowing them to be consumed by worms
according to the standard the cultural
practice led to an epidemic of disease
called kuru also known as laughing death
why is it called laughing death I have
to know that now okay why is kuru called
laughing Oh disease okay let's see the
term kuru derives from the four words ku
Korea Oh Korea to shake due to the body
tremors that are classic simple symptoms
of the disease and kuru itself means
trembling it's known as the Laughing
sickness due to the pathological bursts
of laughter which are a symptom of the
disease videos cannibalism and the
shaking death okay what part of the
internet am I on
I just get put on some [ __ ] watchlist
here potential serial killer you know
it's [ __ ] hilarious I don't know why
I just clicked on this and it's
advertising me this beautiful green
Irish sweater a jumper in this item when
I looked up cannibalism and the shaking
death a new form of disease and a
possible epidemic alright let's get back
to the comedy everybody [ __ ] what a [ __ ]
did I go for the last 10 minutes hail to
the Redskins eating their human
start [ __ ] checking yourself to sleep
alright advice on settling for Less oh
you want advice rip it off this G from
somebody else
alright I can't even sing with my own
[ __ ] song how do i shut this off now
[Music]
what is this that's an outtake from well
what are those guys with the big [ __ ]
heads Charlie Brown gang what do you
call those people you know that was I I
just lost two close is Youssef Kemal
I believe that support Youssef days for
some I don't know what his name is
he went Youssef Kamal now Youssef days
blacked out if that's you if that
interests you because I know that will
just [ __ ] drive you up the wall I
heard this song I need to know what it
is you know it's really funny about
Shazam is how you can just [ __ ] steal
somebody else's coolness somebody's
listening to a cool song and you're not
cool enough to know what it is then you
just steal it and then within ten
minutes you play it around somebody in
your life that you want to impress you
know there has to be a new English word
for that [ __ ] guilt that you feel
afterwards
hey man who is that ah you know like I
know about that song cuz a podcast
listener wrote into me and then I'd like
downloaded some more of the ship it's
not like I don't have an eclectic
musical tastes as people used to always
say on [ __ ] my space I think electic
musical taste advice unsettling for less
I love how eclectic was used to say what
everybody else said about their [ __ ]
musical tastes on MySpace advice on
settling for Less hey Billy Billy no
vice hopefully he's still on the wagon
by this time this gets to you yes I
45 weeks in I told you I was taking a
year off I am seven lucky seven weeks
away before the booze and the tap and
the plucking liquor starts flowing again
actually don't see myself going back
anytime soon I'm not saying I won't
return someday I will return you know
like one of those [ __ ] movies but uh
I don't know I was talking to people and
I just really see like how bad it is for
you I was talking to somebody and the
person told me what their job was and
went really in-depth with it and like I
don't know [ __ ] ten minutes later Ari
told me the whole thing and they'd even
seem like they were that shit-faced
I've want to be a doctor for a while and
I went back to college to finish my
undergrad for that reason but I just
can't seem to shake the feeling that
everyone's smarter than me medical
school is also a huge financial
commitment and I'm broke I feel like I
could be happy just as happy going back
to being a paramedic am i making excuses
or thinking rationally PS you read like
a fourth grader ouch PSS jokes about
first responders a militant military are
hilarious [ __ ] anyone who gets offended
on my behalf thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
all right I think your answer is in the
beginning you said you wanted to be a
doctor for a while so I think you should
be a doctor you should try it all right
I think you got some self-esteem issues
the only way to feel if you're not smart
enough to be a doctor I think if you
become a doctor you're smart enough to
be a doctor right I don't know but I
want to have some dummy [ __ ]
operating on me at some point you said
I've wanted to be a doctor for a while
how long is a while your whole life did
you dream about it as a child or the
last six weeks cuz you change your mind
a lot I have no idea but if you want to
be a doctor I would say go be a doctor
but you know
don't fish it like that is hard I'm
[ __ ] doing this goddamn instrument
[ __ ] and I'm trying to figure out this
whole the HS i gauge when it reverses on
itself I don't [ __ ] get it I don't
get it it doesn't make [ __ ] sense to
me so I'm watching these YouTube videos
and gradually explained it to me
I'm just inching my way through this
[ __ ] and if a dummy like me if dude if
I'm a [ __ ] dope like meek and
actually have the balls to get his
instrument rating on his pilot's license
I think that you can handle becoming a
doctor now the huge financial commitment
that's another thing I mean I don't know
it's a crazy [ __ ] world well then I
guess look I look I think there's gonna
be a lot of money in it okay if we're
gonna be eating each other in the future
and laughing ourselves to death I think
you're picking the right vocation
alright need advice on asking out a
young woman how young whoa way-hey
dear belittle it burr haha get it I get
it
and guilty as charged I'm a 28 year old
guy and I recently got my haircut and a
new salon the young woman that cut my
hair was beautiful and sweet and funny
aren't they always [ __ ] a
hairdressers they're always [ __ ] hot
and [ __ ] cool as [ __ ] you know I find
very rarely do you get your hair cut by
a [ __ ] you know we had a really great
first interaction we grew up in the same
small area had things in common that I
won't bore you with sorry I didn't get a
lot of sleep last night
and make each other smile and laugh well
if this isn't all in your head sir I'll
tell you you're doing great so far at
the end of the appointment she gave me
the salon number to make future
appointments she also gave me her
personal cell phone number to make
appointments with her specifically if I
prefer so here's my question do you
think it would be inappropriate to call
this girl to ask her out on a date she
technically gave her a number as a
stylist so I would hate to overstep my
bounds oh this is an easy one I just
can't look her up
on social media either because I'm not
on there at all I know crazy for someone
in their 20s right I don't trust any of
that [ __ ] haha you're smart person by
the way love your new special paper
tiger and look forward to many more you
old fart you old red fart thanks and go
[ __ ] yourself here's a deal I would just
go get my hair cut by her again you know
if you're smooth I would [ __ ] do the
personal appointment because now you're
more in a more relaxed environment and
it's not weird where you got to try to
ask her out as the next [ __ ] dopes
trying to sit in the chair and she's
sweeping up I would do that way I would
I would call her number like all of
these all of these hairdressers always
get [ __ ] over by this shop so they're
always trying to cut hair on the side so
that's not necessarily a [ __ ] green
like that she's digging you but it kind
of seems like you guys hit it off or
whatever who knows who knows there's a
lot of variables here is she being that
nice and smiling and laughing because
she's trying to get her side business
going here so she can get out from under
the thigh have no idea but it sounds
like she's [ __ ] cool you know that's
a--that's a quite a thing to pull off
throughout a whole [ __ ] haircut if
you're good at reading people so it
seems like you're in the game I would
just do the personal appointment she'll
be in an even better mood because she
won't have to cut any money in for the
salon and whatever you're gonna keep
needing haircuts so you can just
gradually [ __ ] in a very seamless way
work your way that conversation over to
way it needs to go I think you're in
there your biggest problem is not jump
cutting too far ahead where it becomes
whoa hey what's going on I thought I was
just asking you out I mean I was just
cutting your hair now you're asking me
out and what the [ __ ] you know but
you're 28 you shouldn't know how to
[ __ ] do that by now right that's what
I would do I would get the personal
[ __ ] haircut and and I [ __ ] charm
the goddamn pants right off her alright
and that's it for advice with your
liebherr and I've done an hour and 11
minutes so I got to go do something else
all right
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll check in on you
on Thursday
I don't know who's playing tonight I
think the Yankees are playing I'm gonna
watch them I believe the Astros are
playing too it's inevitable two
heavyweights coming together all right
and advice to sports fans that's right
if your team isn't in the playoffs just
sit back and enjoy stress-free playoffs
your team isn't in it it's [ __ ] great
I can sit back and watch all of the
drama of baseball and just enjoy how
great a game it is enjoy how [ __ ]
amazing the athletes are and just not
give a [ __ ] where last year my team was
in it and I hung on every pitch and it
worked out my football team was in it I
hung on every [ __ ] down and it worked
out my hockey team was in it I hung on
every [ __ ] shift and I got my [ __ ]
balls [ __ ] kicked and like they don't
even know each other and they they got
kicked so [ __ ] hard in that game
seven that they still haven't come back
together again doesn't always work out
so you know when your team doesn't make
the playoffs you can really see it in a
positive way that's how I look at it and
that's one to grow on
go [ __ ] yourselves I'll see you on
Thursday